PREST TRUMP IS NOW R "
ATLAIC LE AND
SUS IT TO
>> TO SWEARN ANYTHING THAT I NE.
THERE IS THATESPECTS
THEM MORE.
THINK IT'S A
HORRIBLE THING.
WE MADE GREAT INTO
FRANKLY A VER SADNG WHE . ANIMA
WONG?
>> WE SHO NOTEHATNN AS NOTIS RE.
WE ARE JOINED BY JEFFREY
GOLDBERG, THIT HE BROKE T STORY.
HEOED THIS
AT NDA LOS AND WE KNOWHA
TRUE. CDOHN McCAIN EXACTLY 15 LU
YOUR RESPOE L OF
THIS STO RNG THE VISIT
B WOOD PARIS IN 2018.
HO D ANSWERHO
>> I BY MYORTING
CEIS WHAPP S
I STAND IT.  LETEEAD SOME OF TH
REPORTING THAT YOUNG
OU THE
YOE SO MANYS, AS YOU'LL T
CEMETE BELLA WOOD WED, SO BACK ?
SORTINGCONVERSATION WITH SR
ME WHY  THATME
REFERIVE AUCKERS ET HE ASKE
D GUYS  WAR?
AIDAND WHY
THEES WOULDENE ONF THE
ALLIES. JEREY, MEAN, OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S - JAW
DROPPING STUFF BUT
CHALLENGE YOUR EVENTS
OR YOUR REPORTED VERSI THE
EVENTS BECAUSE JOHN BOLTON I HI
HAD A VERY DIFFERENT VERSION.
SO LET ME O YOU HE,
WHO WAS THERE, SAID THAT
THER WAS ONE'S CREWAS SAYING
ISIT IMPRUDENT TO CHOPPEHE
TE.
COMBAT, BUT FORHE POTUS
DIFFERT. NECESSA I MALONGOTNG A
EVENY.
REY RESPONSE IS I'M SURE A
OF
I HAVE HEARD PEOPLET THE -INES
A IUL THE IDEA
ARINES COU THE RAIN.
T LRNT IS IS TMP EXES AIDES HI
DESIRE TO GO TO THE CEMETERY AND
NOT TO 90 MINUTES IECAUSEEDOESN
UNDERSTAND WHY ONE WOULD GO PAY
THATEV FALLEN
AM
THE WAY,ESSEDLYHAT THE RAIN
WHICH WAS QUITE HEAVY AT TIMES
WOULD  W.
>> LISTEN, I HAVERTED STORIES T
KNE D NIED BY THE WHITE HOUSE, D
STORIES THAT ->>S,HE
AWARE OET
BECAUSE THESE ARE REMARKABLE
AC OF AN
CHIEF STATING THE MOST
DISRESPEL E ABOUTMBPROU KNOW --
DO
I'M CURIOUS WHY THESOPLE
DI WN THE RECORD.
WEWO MONTHS FROM THE
ELECTION AND THESE ARE
SUMEEXPLN THINKING
TOULDN'T P NAMES T TAC Y WHEN
SAME SITUATION,OU FN R  YOU HTO
GO ANDOTH EXPERIENCELE DON'T WA
THEYON TED
WITH ARY TET ALL THE
REST. THAT'S WHY
HASORT OF THIS REPORTING WITH E
OWTED Is AND CAND F MULTIPLE SR
CA RIC'S INTEREST IN
ING THIS INFORMATION
EIGH THEIGUITIES OR ULTIES
DECIDED THATEWHI ENOUGH FROM
HIGH E SOU
SOURCES T I THOUGHT STI DO OBVI
TH RECO.
H'SEFFO- HOPE
TH ON THEARREPORTERS AND I'LL BG
TO MAKE THAT EFFORT TO MOVEECTLE
RE.  WHITE HOUSE ISIN STRONGLY-N
NEGATIVE
REMEMBER R
TYY.IS REPORT IS ENT TR
MILITARY RERDIS COMMITMENT
HEM AT EVERY TUVERING ON HIS
GIVE OURRO MUCH NEEDED
PAYAI INCREASING MILITARYSP
VETEFOSUPRYSPOUS. ANDNSIVE WING
D PNTHAT "THE N FOLLONGSTOR CON
OF THE AIL NOT   ISHA HASHEQUES
IT"T" IS THATH
AT THEIR JOBS SO WHY DO WE MAKE?
YOU S OF THESE
COMMENTS, GOING ALL THE WAY BACK
TO5 DISPAGEDMcCAIN FORNG,
S ADERSTANDING AUTOLDIERNDHA CE
FR COMMENTS RIGHT TO TODAY.
>> JEFFREY --
>> VERY QUICKLY INOTE,
THE FORMER  S HE
CONFIRMED AND DETAILING YOND TH
ED TO HALF-STAFF AFTERN McCAINA
>> JEFFREY GOLDBERG, WE HAVEANED